Olá e bem-vindo de volta à série de cursos sobre o Variational Quantum Eigensolver.
Meu nome é Victoria Lipinska e neste vídeo vamos mergulhar em como representar
um dado problema de VQE de uma forma que o computador quântico entenda.
Tipicamente, um problema de química quântica é expresso em termos de energias
do sistema.
Chamamos de Hamiltoniano o operador que descreve essas energias.
Primeiro, precisamos quantizá-lo.
Ou seja, expressá-lo na linguagem da química quântica,
que é formalmente chamada de segunda quantização.
Se o Hamiltoniano descreve interações de férmions, por exemplo,
energia de elétrons em orbitais de spin, chamamos isso
de Hamiltoniano fermiônico, e esse será nosso ponto de partida hoje.
Os qubits, porém, têm sua própria linguagem.
Os operadores no mundo dos qubits são descritos pelos operadores de Pauli.
Então nosso foco aqui é expressar os operadores fermiônicos
em termos de operadores de qubit.
Existe uma correspondência simples um a um entre
os estados zero e um para férmions e qubits.
Portanto, o mapeamento entre os estados também é direto.
No entanto, o mapeamento dos operadores é um pouco mais complexo.
Mas os Hamiltonianos fermiônicos são expressos com operadores de criação e
aniquilação.
Então nosso trabalho é facilitar a compreensão do
Hamiltoniano pelo computador quântico.
Vamos usar ferramentas matemáticas para mapear um Hamiltoniano fermiônico
em um Hamiltoniano de qubit com gates.
Em outras palavras, vamos traduzir entre
a linguagem da química quântica e a linguagem da computação quântica.
Imagine duas cadeias, uma com férmions,
ou seja, a linguagem da química quântica.
E outra com qubits, ou seja, a linguagem da computação quântica.
À primeira vista, o mapeamento parece direto, não é?
Em ambos os casos, vemos sistemas com dois níveis.
Para os férmions, temos ou um férmion no estado
ou nenhum férmion.
E para os qubits, temos o estado 0 ou o estado 1.
No entanto, é mais sutil do que isso.
A diferença entre uma cadeia de qubits e uma cadeia de férmions
é algo muito fundamental na física: o que chamamos de simetria de troca.
Dois férmions nunca podem ocupar o mesmo estado.
No entanto, para uma cadeia de qubits, isso é completamente diferente.
Dois qubits podem estar no mesmo estado,
já que um qubit não é um férmion.
Agora precisamos encontrar uma forma de traduzir entre as duas cadeias.
Já em 1928, dois pesquisadores, Jordan e Wigner,
mostraram que os operadores fermiônicos para toda a cadeia
podem ser representados exatamente em termos de operadores de qubit.
Esse é o mapeamento mais direto para um computador quântico.
Por exemplo, pode-se usar isso para mapear a ocupação
de um orbital para o spin de um qubit.
Na prática, esse mapeamento para um Hamiltoniano resulta em uma soma ponderada de operadores de Pauli.
Esse é um fato muito importante, que gostaria que você tivesse em mente,
e voltaremos a isso no próximo módulo, onde falaremos
sobre como os circuits variacionais são executados no computador quântico.
O mapeamento acima significa que, se tivéssemos, por exemplo,
14 operadores fermiônicos, mapearíamos o problema para 14 qubits.
Felizmente, existem formas inteligentes de reduzir o número de qubits
e usar menos recursos quânticos para obter um desempenho melhor do computador quântico.
Tipicamente, em um sistema molecular, vamos conhecer
algumas simetrias físicas do Hamiltoniano,
por exemplo, o número total de elétrons é fixo.
Essa informação pode ser usada para reduzir o tamanho do problema
sem perder nenhuma informação relevante.
Chamamos essa técnica de redução do espaço ativo.
Isso permite a redução do número de recursos, ou seja, o número de qubits,
antes do mapeamento de qubits como a transformação Jordan-Wigner.
Essa etapa calcula um Hamiltoniano efetivo
e nos permite usar menos qubits como resultado.
No nosso exemplo com 14 orbitais,
essa técnica reduz o número de qubits para apenas seis.
Agora podemos ir ainda mais longe com essas reduções.
Podemos usar mapeamentos diferentes,
que são um pouco mais elaborados do que o Jordan-Wigner.
O exemplo mais comum é o mapeamento de paridade.
O mapeamento de paridade não mapeia a ocupação dos orbitais nos qubits,
mas sim a paridade dos orbitais em qubits individuais.
Não vamos entrar nos detalhes matemáticos aqui,
mas o importante a saber é que esse mapeamento contém
redundâncias adicionais que podem ser usadas para remover mais dois qubits.
Portanto, nosso exemplo com 14 orbitais reduz de 14 qubits
para 6 qubits com a redução do espaço ativo e depois para 4 qubits
com a redução de dois qubits no mapeamento de paridade.
Vamos mencionar brevemente mais uma transformação.
Outro mapeamento comumente usado entre a representação
fermiônica e a de qubit é a transformação Bravyi-Kitaev.
A transformação Bravyi-Kitaev usa qubits para codificar a informação
tanto sobre o número de ocupação quanto sobre a paridade do estado quântico.
A transformação Bravyi-Kitaev combina informações de número de ocupação e paridade
para uma base de orbitais moleculares de tamanho N,
onde são usados novamente N qubits.
No entanto, a informação armazenada em cada qubit
varia dependendo de qual qubit é.
Ou seja, quando o índice do qubit é par,
ele armazena o número de ocupação do
orbital correspondente, como no mapeamento Jordan-Wigner.
Quando o índice do qubit é ímpar, o qubit armazena a paridade de um determinado
conjunto de números de ocupação. A transformação Bravyi-Kitaev é a mais eficiente
quando o número de qubits se aproxima de uma potência de dois.
O mapeamento Bravyi-Kitaev combina as vantagens do Jordan-Wigner
e das transformações de paridade.
Ele reduz o número de qubits em que cada termo do Hamiltoniano atua,
o que é importante para a simulação quântica, pois termos
que atuam em um grande número de qubits no Hamiltoniano
exigem circuits mais longos para sua simulação.
Isso significa que a profundidade do circuit
é reduzida com a transformação Bravyi-Kitaev e, em geral,
podemos obter melhores resultados com o hardware.
Isso é uma melhoria em relação à transformação Jordan-Wigner,
que resulta em um Hamiltoniano de qubit de ordem N.
Então, neste vídeo exploramos métodos para mapear
um Hamiltoniano fermiônico em um Hamiltoniano de qubit.
No próximo, veremos como selecionar melhor o estado
e uma forma variacional ou um circuit.
Até lá.